[Music]
foreign
we're talking about the fine-tuning
argument I take the fine-tuning argument
to be sort of an extension of of a very
basic it's not even an argument it's
just kind of an instinct you know why do
most people who've ever lived and still
live believe that there's a god well one
of the reasons might be if you look
around at the universe and there are
various bits and pieces of it that seem
to fit well together in a way that you
might think you know needs a mind
foreign
advanced technology is indistinguishable
from Magic
[Music]
Dr Luke Barnes joining me in person in
an undisclosed location for undisclosed
reasons we've been brought together
do you expect me to believe that
Mr Barnes uh Dr Barnes is a lecturer at
the University I always forget the
University of is it Western it was the
University of Western Sydney and then
they paid a lot of money to change it to
Western Sydney University you know how
much Consulting fees
did you change Mascots from the fighting
I wasn't there thank goodness from the
fighting wallaby to the uh to the dingos
uh it's a pleasure of meet you in person
yeah yeah we last spoke uh together
about two years ago for a previous book
of yours called The Cosmic
revolutionaries handbook which laid out
the case
um for sort of proponents of
alternatives to the standard Big Bang
cold Dark Matter cosmology what they
would have to do to overthrow it
overturn it and maybe we'll start there
um how does it feel to have your book
utterly obliterated by the forces that
have proven Based on jwst data that the
Big Bang never happened how do you feel
Luke how will you ever recover I'm not
devastating glow or what's your take on
it in all seriousness uh I think
collectively a lot of cosmologists so
what we're referring to jwst results
came out and a a a paper as an article
came out from Eric Lerner and this was
treated as something new something
dangerous something's going to overthrow
The Establishment panic and panic yeah
and without going into too much
basically there's the same um objections
to the big bang that he published in
1993 without a lot of changes uh there's
two things to say about it one is
there's been plenty of this isn't a
secret there are plenty of online people
who are in cosmology
um who who responded to those critiques
you know weigh them up yourself and the
other thing is it was really it wasn't
really about the big bang it was about
the physics of how galaxies formed so at
worst the worst case scenario we need to
rethink the way we think that matter
collects into galaxies in the universe
but it didn't really touch the expansion
of space the the hot big bang the sort
of the real pillars of The Big Bang
Theory yeah uh when we look at the big
bang previous books of yours uh
including with uh your former advisor
right uh those so the cosmic
revolutionary sandbox is Garrett Lewis
you're a former advisor
um and uh who's at New South Wales is
that right uh Sydney University in in
New Zealand in New South Wales it sounds
confusing you know it's everything's
upside down uh
um we we had a conversation recently as
well but you also wrote a book uh prior
to that uh with him I mean the name of
that Luke it's called a fortunate
universe life in a finely tuned Cosmos
so I thought we'd start there a lot of
the discussions that we've been having
this this week um with eminent
scientists from around the world tend to
involve around around things pertinent
to biology chemical life formation the
improbability of forming a lipid cell
structure and a eukaryotic life and and
so forth very stimulating I would say
you know this this positive one way or
another but oftentimes we look at the
universe and we're told it's extremely
finely too and that no secret would lead
to the title of that book a fortunate
Universe fortunate implying some
teleological purpose and maybe some some
ultimate uh ultimate beneficence of
something or someone or some Force so
what is fine-tuning first of all where
does it come from and what is the the
weak anthropic principle whap uh and how
is it how does it all come together in
the cosmological argument
so the nice thing about that book with
gray was we uh you know I'm I'm a
Christian he's an atheist we wrote that
book together and most of it we wrote
together the last chapter as a sort of
debate about what it all means but on
this fine-tuning issue here's what a
Christian a theist and uh and an atheist
can agree about the science so he
interprets fortunate as Lucky in in the
context of a Multiverse but the thing we
agree on is something that's turned up
in the in the physics literature over
the last sort of 40 or 50 years where
there are these fundamental constants of
nature when we boil things down as we
love to as physicists to the deepest
equations we can find there are some
basic properties of the universe that
just need to go into those equations how
heavy is an electron how strong are the
forces between them
um and into the standard cosmological
model uh what's the ratio of dark matter
to baryonic matter ordinary matter
um what's the value of the cosmological
constant which is causing the expansion
of the universe to accelerate
they're they're just numbers just that
you can look them up there's some number
that all of these are and what's been
just sort of
discovered almost accidentally if if
um well certainly it wasn't expected
over the last 50 years was as as
theoretical physicists asked what if we
changed them we don't know why they are
what they are so let's at least ask the
question what if they've been different
you find universes which are perfectly
mathematically fine as a you know we can
write equations down and we can solve
those but
um for a number of those constants over
the range in which the equations are
fine with them what you might think is
there what's possible
you only get an interesting Universe
like this which has any sort of
structure in it at all including life
for a very small range of the constants
so this is called the fine tuning of the
universe for life and as I said you know
two scientists who have very different
beliefs about what's really underneath
it or can at least agree on what happens
when you change these numbers yeah we'll
get into I'll play the discussion of you
know what fine-tuning is how it could be
accomplished in a moment but before we
do
um recently I've been reading some work
by Fred Adams at U University of
Michigan and and he's been on the
podcast although I think I may have
deleted the recording or by accident by
accident
before I became such a pro as you guys
couldn't tell out there and in uh
internet land
um I want to do it again yeah because he
is a phenomenal thinker and he was at UC
San Diego visiting his close colleague
George Fuller is a good friend of mine
um and in his most recent papers which I
believe will be a book supported I
believe at a Templeton Foundation if I'm
not mistaken uh which kind of ironic
10th and Foundation tends to support
things that seek synthesis if not
Harmony between science and religion and
some people have a problem with that be
that as it may
um Fred argues that no in fact some of
these wide ranging phenomena are are
actually broadly tuned or you know
coarsely tuned for example he sets the
stage which is the first comment I'd
like you to make
um when we apply our perspective from
the weak anthropic principle we're
necessarily filtering out a whole host
of variables to concentrate on a select
few variables
um and his uh and his kind of rubric he
looks at stars what would it take to
find Stars gravitational forces
electromagnetic forces nuclear forces
and he finds there's a huge parameter
space to use his words it's not
improbable at all
um first of all I want to ask you is
there necessarily kind of an anthropic
bias when you have to when you search
out well what does it mean to be finely
tuned and then second of all how do you
react to his claim that no the universe
Ain't So finely tuned after all
so uh first of all Fred's doing
absolutely first First Rate work on this
it's it's really great really helpful
um I've tried to sort of follow a little
bit in these footsteps and so I've
published a few papers on this as well
uh it what Fred one way I would
summarize some of his work is to say
that stars turned out to be more robust
than we gave them credit for so in the
early fine-tuning literature this goes
back quite early actually it's in 1970 I
think it's a paper by Freeman Dyson who
said first guest on the podcast oh
wonderful oh um if you uh if I've got it
right I'm on it wrong anyway uh in our
universe if you take a proton and a
proton and you smash them together they
will not stick to each other those two
will fall apart the way the sun uh
operates is you take a proton a proton
smash them together and you hope that in
that instant where they're close to each
other thanks to something called the
nuclear weak Force proton turns into a
neutron and proton plus Neutron will
stick together yeah um
what uh Dyson had argued is that if you
had a very small increase in the
strength of the force that sticks those
two types of particles together you
could actually stick a proton and a
proton to each other and if that
happened Stars would be explosive
because now it's really easy you don't
have to wait for the weak Force to turn
one of them into a neutron proton proton
bang you know you just blow everything
up what Fred pointed out quite rightly
is that
um that's not true a star is what we
call a thermodynamic system where the
the micro details of it of reaction
rates are actually controlled by the
overall balances of of of heat and
energy flowing so you won't get an
explosive star you'll simply get a star
which is cooler in its Center and we'll
we'll react appropriately to the fuel
it's got to to power itself so actually
you can have perfectly long-lived stars
in those sorts of universes and and this
is what need needs to happen in this
fine-tuning anthropic principle kind of
Investigation we need to know what
happens when these constants change and
and sometimes because it's not our
universe we're thinking about you know
weird Alternatives sometimes we get it
wrong and we just have to rethink it and
Fred's done some great work so stars
turn out to be more
um robust and than perhaps we thought I
think there there's there is in fact one
way he discovered Where Stars can fall
apart in a way we didn't think of before
if you look at his 2008 paper and you
change the strength of electromagnetism
there is there's a famous plot in there
I say famous I've looked at it a billion
times uh
where we knew staff would be in trouble
if electromagnetism was too strong but
it turns out there's a way they could be
in trouble if they're too weak as well
as it's a two-sided thing there but in
general yeah stars are quite robust you
can you can sort of Hope in any old
Universe you might get stars to fire up
and and be long-lived the main driver of
the the the uh lengths of the sort of
Lifetime the stars is really in the
strength of gravity rather than the
nuclear that for a wide range of
parameters the nuclear uh property the
nuclear reactions will adjust
um but overall I think that there's
still very strong cases of fine-tuning
that we've done you know calculations
again and again and refined them as
Fred's done as I've done as as other
people have done looking more deeply and
and they have retained their look here's
a set of possibilities and it's only a
small subset where life can exist so yes
yes of course we keep doing calculations
to refine it but I wouldn't say it's
it's
this isn't just any old universe and
when we look at the you know overall
kind of um sieve you know that that
physicists apply to the observations and
then select out certain components that
we think are this positive or might be
this positive towards the origin of life
and evolution of life I find it you know
sort of the physical concepts are almost
the easy part um and I kind of make an
analogy towards well covid-19 and it's
one of our first you know it's the first
time we meeting in public and it's the
first you know when some of the first
in-person podcasts around the
opportunity to do yeah yeah um and I
think back to 2019 when we were building
assignments Observatory which is my
ongoing project with 300 collaborators
around the world including some in
Australia you'll be pleased to them and
uh and we're putting it together and you
know to do that properly we had to have
a analysis of risks to the project and
so we had things like the Chilean Peso
might fluctuate against the Euro which
is where we build some of the hard metal
works that we have and then concrete
comes from Bolivia and maybe come you
know their shipping child you know
whatever there's some fluctuations and
there's stochastic processes you could
model those and and uh it could be a
strike and you could even have some
punctuated things yeah it happens in
South America you never know yeah these
are the experimentalists we have to be
uh quite caught on top of things uh from
from many different angles but one thing
we didn't have no one had it was Global
pandemic shuts down the world for two
and a half years uh causing things like
you know my graduate student I can't
just say to her you know see in two
years I'm gonna stop paying you now and
uh come back in two years no we had him
it's a stand so we did but um it's sort
of to bring up the notion of these
punctuations these radical things that
occur in order for there to be life on
Earth
um you know and why we think that the
physical properties of the universe are
the most contingent and and so I guess
you know if you had a select a few you
know kind of uh from your studies of of
the fortunate nature of the universe
what are some of the ones that speak
loudest to you of some perhaps you know
or organization of the Universe I don't
want to say designer if you want to it's
fine but um but how do you what do you
feel are some of the most pertinent and
calculatable properties of the universe
that that we can draw some conclusions
about how fortunate we are or not yeah
because it's we're at the level of of
fundamental physics and we're trying to
go from these fundamental constants up
actually it's really hard to do
calculations right from the bottom up to
anything even from quarks to protons but
this is all the stuff you discover when
you start digging in that's really hard
and then protons at a nuclei to atoms
so what we really focus on when we do
try and do fine-tuning work is is there
a it's sort of the reverse of the
question you've asked is there a real
disaster somewhere in Spain in in in
possibility space parameter space that
that's going to help that's going to be
obvious that okay no structure over
there and some of the more obvious ones
uh if you look at the masses of the
fundamental particles that we're made
out of so famously there's the electron
in our atoms that thing going around the
outside there's Pro there's there's
sorry up clocks and down clocks that
make protons and neutrons so how heavy
are those and there's a number there we
can that's very small in any sort of
kilogram scale and the then then the
sort of particle physicists get to work
saying what happens if you start
changing these numbers and you map out
the three-dimensional space and and you
can see it mapped out in the book but
some of the really interesting kind of
disasters are things like
if you change the the numbers that say
the masses of the quarks in a certain
way
um you end up the the lightest kind of
particle that you can make out of three
quarks right is not the proton or the
neutron it's something else it's a three
up quarks or the Delta plus particle if
you're in a universe where that's the
most stable thing you can make out of
the Quark here's the problem you could
through the very simple energy arguments
come to the conclusion that a a Delta
plus particle build a plus plus particle
will not stick to another one ever right
and so suddenly your periodic table is
gone because because that proton sticks
to Neutron sticks to everything else
that's how you build up all the nuclei
on the periodic table suddenly all
you've got is a particle with the mat
with the charge of two electrons so it
has the chemistry of helium which is to
say no chemistry at all and suddenly
you've got a universe where it's just so
drastically simpler than our universe
you you if you want to write a chemistry
textbook there's one element in the
periodic table there's no chemical
reactions that's a pretty easy textbook
to write except there's nothing to write
it on or with uh and so it's those sorts
of cases
where once you start to see those sorts
of things inhabiting big swathes of the
way the universe could have been
um you start to really think that okay
there's something interesting going on
around here you know 92 stable elements
in the periodic table the chemistry of
carbon we've really got it going on
around here another one that that
cosmologists will be more familiar with
is just a cosmological constant
um it's it's a famous that's called the
cosmological constant problem which says
you know we've discovered in our
universe something that's making the
expansion accelerate so galaxies are not
just moving away from us they're moving
faster today than they were yesterday
and
um what could be doing that well it
turns out in in the way we
describe the fundamental structure of
particles around us we use things called
Fields so an electron is really a sort
of Ripple in an electron field
and if it were the case that even when
there's no particles in a particular
place there's still some energy there
that would that would cause the
expansion the universe to accelerate it
has that that effect on that
gravitational effect on space-time and
if you then use a kind of calculation
that we can do in other places in in
Quantum field theory of how does you
know how does the structure of the
vacuum the structure of the field when
nothing's there when no particles are
there uh how does that structure you
know add up to an energy difference you
end up with a rough calculation that
would predict an enormous value of the
cosmological constant and that's a
problem because it's another very easy
way to make sure there's no structure in
the universe because space would expand
so fast that that no particles are ever
near each other so even if this proton
and this Neutron could come together to
make something there are trillion likes
is upon and it's these sorts of
disasters where okay we can we can
debate
structures of stars there's some really
interesting edge cases and and
complicated cases but there's some real
proper disasters waiting us out there in
in sort of the ways that according to
best physics we have the universe could
have been but isn't our
any of the arguments you think capable
of convincing somebody you know of the
existence of some sort of overarching
teleological purpose uh for these or do
you think you know they'll always be
sort of room for doubt I spoke to uh Jim
tour with this conference earlier
um in the day and and asked him you know
as as a as a you know someone who is
practicing but might be considered
agnostic myself
um I do practice and contradistinction
of people like Freeman Dyson who has
called himself agnostic but didn't do
anything different than women Dyson than
uh Richard Dawkins didn't go to the same
church that Friedman Dyson didn't go to
uh but but you know wondering is there
any kind of um you know hope of of
convincing people I usually feel like I
don't engage in debates because science
isn't done that way and also because you
never change your mind like I don't know
if you guys have prime minister debates
and and uh and I'll show I assume you do
at some level they're a bit pathetic
yeah but we know I mean we never oh yeah
oh Trump made a great argument let me
just I'm gonna vote for him you know I
don't find him a objectionable at all uh
but you know how do you how do you view
this is it is it sort of just people
wanting to vent their own ideas without
any help of really convincing the other
side or could you see your faith
strengthened or maybe weakened by an
argument you know either on your side or
on maybe in opposition
yeah the one thing that all of this so I
started looking into this sort of almost
by accident during my PhD the one thing
I can't predict is how people react to
it it's kind of hilarious one of the
reasons carraine and I wrote a book on
this is because uh I wrote a review
paper uh um in 2012 and then um so
people ask me I'll give you a talk on
that stuff that looks interesting just
at the
um at Sydney University where I was at
the time and uh you know the department
turns up
give us just pretty standard talk
um Grant was there as well as everyone
else and then something happened that
I've not seen before or since which 45
minute talk and an hour and a half of
questions afterwards everyone just sat
around which is amazing because it was
lunch time but no one left and not just
that there were questions but
immediately people have not just
opinions but different opinions and so
someone would ask a question and someone
else would answer it and then someone
else would reply to that and so it
wasn't just people wanted to get
information out of me I'd laid the
ground rules and now everyone wanted to
talk about what this meant and I've seen
that again and again and again in in as
talking to you know talking churches I
talk in like Skeptics in the pub uh
groups all sorts of you know amateur
astronomy societies and more than any
other topic I've ever seen in my life
people just immediately are like
uh either either this has got to mean
something or I know what this means and
I have to tell everyone
um and yeah it just has that effect and
I love it for it because I love a the
physics is wonderful how this affects
this and that affects that and these
equations it's beautiful uh and then
just the way it lights people up and so
there's every reaction to this under the
sun I mean me personally I already
believed in God and so this was sort of
I don't have a problem here I've I've
heard of uh of someone else who did a
talk on on fine tuning
um uh and then someone in the audience
said afterwards look I don't believe in
God I'm not sorry I'm not religious but
something weird is happening here and I
think that impression is sort of there
but um what I love about it is people
can't sit still in their seats someone
it just it just draws opinions out of
people you have to have an opinion now
apologize for the the siren sound in the
background you know there's uh some
Caribbean area somewhere chasing after
somebody that's what I call them the
carbonary because they're always uh
pasta some wine emergency up the
mountain right
there's no more um so uh getting back to
uh sort of more you know in the
technical uh side of things that your
research is is concerned with isn't
actually not these topics you're
actually practicing as a theoretical
cosmologist uh on a daily basis you were
talking earlier in the week about you
know a course that you're teaching maybe
for undergraduates where you get into
actually philosophical arguments uh but
not necessarily pertinence
can you talk more about your teaching it
sounded very interesting and we talked a
little about quantum mechanics and this
Aristotle have anything to do with
quantum mechanics so what is the role of
of the Ancients because you know in my
conception Aristotle yeah basically has
the highest ratio of Fame to number of
things he got right uh you know I can
only think of one thing that was officer
I mean could have discovered just by
dropping this and I'm not going to do it
but dropping these two things at way
very different amounts back then that
they don't hit the ground at the same
time now one doesn't fall faster than
the other as he presupposes now do it
with a leaf okay I'll do it right I go
to the Moon well so this is uh there's
so many wonderful wonderful things to
talk about there let me start with the
teaching I I got put in charge of a
course at Western Sydney called
scientific literacy and all the first
year science students take it and what
it was was a number of fingers it was
sort of well a welcome to University
here's how to do well and here's how to
reference properly and research properly
so let's just make sure all that's good
you know don't plagiarize all that sort
of stuff don't
um how to how to write properly which is
something I'm actually quite passionate
about how to give a talk properly and
then there's a real chance to take a
couple of lectures just to say what's
this science thing what are we actually
doing here and there's two approaches
that I take that one's a very very rapid
History of Science broadly construed
where that I you know I don't think
science by one definition science
started with the Scientific Revolution
but on a more broad let's try and
understand the world we live in it's a
very human activity so we have experts
in um Aboriginal Australian Aboriginal
astronomy at Western Sydney so I was
able to get one of those experts Ray
Norris to give a 20-minute talk on that
which was really fascinating
um as a as uh yeah we can talk about
that if you want uh but but the
Babylonians the Greeks and what so
getting under Aristotle I have I have a
very high regard for Aristotle part of
that comes from
um a few things there's a wonderful book
uh the the man's surname is l-e-r-o-i
and I I suspect it's not pronounced
Leroy but uh maybe something French
that's equivalent to that uh it's called
our it's called um Aristotle's Lagoon
and he read all of Aristotle's immense
works on
um biology and as in a modern biologist
we could sort of try to understand
untangle the logic of why he thought
that when he's wrong why is he wrong and
what does he get right and there's there
is a remarkably
hard deep thinker and a close Observer
of nature in Aristotle this idea that he
just sat in an armchair like this no no
of course I mean but that's a paradox of
him so one thing that I the one thing
that sticks in my mind that he got right
maybe in the lagoon was that whales or
mammals not fish as men people have
thought for a millennia right so you
know so therefore he he was aware of the
observational component of the free
scientific method and just to you know
rebut just to be a little bit more harsh
on him than I know you are yeah I'm a
big fan of his too but but let me just
say that you know it's not like Galileo
had like the Large Hadron Collider
available
a couple hundred miles from here he
dropped uh some you know some objects
that were available Aristotle from a
height available to Aristotle did the
observation said no and art and did a
thought experiment if you have two
masses connected by a string are they
one mass of a given weight no so you
could do the thought experiment or the
actual experiment and it seems to me
that Aristotle didn't either not
condemning him but what can we learn
um about about you know the scientific
method from somebody who was often at
least in the physical sciences yeah
that's a that's a crucial question
that's a very good way to put it I think
here's one of the things which is is is
logical if you're Aristotle but with
hindsight actually causes a lot of the
problems he he made a distinction
between natural motion and violent
motion so if if I drop something and it
it falls to the ground he's saying well
it's made of Earth Earth natural places
at the bottom of the universe and so
it's seeking out its natural place if I
lift it back up again that's something
violent I'm doing I'm moving it away
from its place and so that requires an
agent if you think that then
experimentation is violent motion you're
not seeing nature you're seeing what
you're interfering right where so
um we think of and it's so natural to us
when when I when we say
um if you drop two things with different
masses they fall at the same rate and
the thing you have to remember is that
what we're putting in Brackets after
that is in a vacuum now Aristotle age
didn't believe in a vacuum but more
importantly that's not a very natural
state right let's suck all the air out
and then see what happens and Aristotle
will be saying well of course you're
messing with nature when you do that if
I just take a piece of paper and a rock
they fall at different speeds that's the
thing we want to explain uh and so
I'd say it's it's amazing how subtle
little things like that shape so much of
the way that you move the that you you
view the world
um and in there's another thing which is
um sometimes pointed out all these are a
little bit oversimplified but
um whereas Plato was a mathematician
um Aristotle wanted to classify things
so he didn't want to measure he want to
classify things and that probably comes
out of actually at heart he's a
biologist uh and and if you see nature
you don't immediately start I don't see
that tree and immediately want to start
counting with leaves and I don't think
it might it went to all the effort
there'd be some beautiful mathematical
law there and and so that emphasis on
what I need to do to Nature is classify
um um it then you know the thought that
if I really went and measured some stuff
I might discover some laws there is
something that takes a while for people
to realize they can that can be done
so soon they'll be calling us for you
know another 2 000 calorie helping of
pasta and bread which Luke and I want to
partake of so um let's do a little bit
of Rapid Fire kind of questions
um and just playing off the last topic
we just talked about Aristotle
um if you give your students a set of
books only one set would you give them
or her the collective works of Aristotle
or the Feynman lectures on physics I
have to say fine then okay
um
there's there there is there's two
Brilliant Minds there of course yes and
I mean I don't want I don't want to say
that you know oh they're just as good as
each other no look the last couple of
thousand years we really have learned
some stuff about the way the universe
works and it's more
I'd like to think Aristotle would want
fireman's books as well certainly would
have a lot a lot to glean from them
um one recapitulation on the fine-tuning
problem so you know Sean Carroll has
passed multiple multiple time guests on
the show as you are now doing a Pantheon
of two-time guests on the show
so you know there's no need for God it's
a as a as a theory that's you know you
know barely useful or you know maybe one
of the least useful it's still a theory
it's still there's no need for it
um and in that context we he and I
talked a long time ago about you know to
take the standard model in his book the
big picture and you see where are these
couplings and which couplings could
couple to an agent and there's really
nothing in there that could do that and
I phrase it a little differently when I
spoke with Stephen C Meyer a couple of
almost two years ago now for his book
The Return of the gun I bought this said
how does an intelligent agent you know
instantiate you know is there some knobs
and when does uh he uh you know in like
judeo-christian said when does he start
in the manipulate is it like at the uh
ABN phase you know bringing elements is
it at the Stellar Evolution phase is it
at the genetic Evolution phase so and
how do you think of it like how does the
tuning get done
I mean I if I had to you know allow me
down on something I I think the initial
conditions so there's a wonderful quote
from John Wheeler in his book at home in
the universe actually it's a collection
of essays but it's in there somewhere
where he says nothing is clearer in
paraphrasing but almost nothing is clear
in physics
um than what is and what isn't physics
so the laws that govern the way
particles move yes the initial
velocities no right the initial
conditions are really something else so
if you're that that choice that you have
to make there between say the way I view
the world and say sure the way Sean
views the world is I assume if you're
Sean if there are something like initial
conditions they're just
the start of explanations and that's it
so he has
um there's a quote from his that I use a
lot because I think it's very clear
which is you know there are his view is
that there is a chain of explanations in
the universe which reaches the ultimate
laws of nature and stops and part of
those laws of nature would be just
initial conditions all boundary
conditions or whatever they yeah this is
no sorry Carol okay Carol said that
um and so you know either the choice is
not between do you just let the universe
run itself or do you have someone
sticking their finger in it's
whatever these initial conditions are
are they just it or do you think there's
some cause deeper than that in reality
um so maybe I'll close I usually have
four existential questions we only have
time for one
um so in uh Sabina hasenfelder's most
recent book existential questions or
existential physics which you've got
from my topic calling uh things
existential questions I'm sure uh there
is uh there you are referred to and I
wanna I wanna appropriately reference
the quote but first let me preface it by
saying the progenitor of the name of
this show is our Sir Arthur C Clarke
um who came up with the phrase the only
way to determine the limits of the
possible is to go beyond them into the
impossible but another thing that he
said is when an elderly but
distinguished scientist says something
is possible he is very likely correct
when he says something is impossible he
is most very mostly wrong I want to ask
you as described by Sabina as a
middle-aged scientist you're not elderly
uh but you are distinguished I won't say
the other adjectives she describes uh
Ubi but that's you know that's just her
favorite commercial way of doing things
what have you changed your mind on if
anything looks like so in science no I'm
going to say what it was she we had a a
discussion on it's on YouTube you can go
and find it and she said something
reporting on this letter to something
online for Barnes turned out to be a big
faced middle-aged man with the ears
round face or whatever it was and I I
cut that quote out of the book I got the
book and then put it on my Facebook page
and everyone who knows me thought that
was the funniest thing they'd ever seen
he's probably got the most likes of
anything I put on any social media
platform so thanks
um I laughed my head off that's
fantastic what have I changed my mind
about uh I grew up young Earth
creationist that's that's the that's the
background that I grew up in that was
the church but in Australia where it
wasn't
so for example
um there was a debate between the pastor
who happened to be my father and the
local
um science teacher at the local high
school who also went to the church but
on the validity of evolution
um as a theory and people turned up and
it was quite I just remember it being
quite cordial and it was fine and you
know it wasn't like people ran him out
of the church or something like so it
was it was it seems odd to say you have
to sort of say this in the American
context it was young Earth creationists
but somehow not dogmatic right
um over the course of them getting um
you know I was good at maths obviously
I'm now an astrophysicist uh going to
University learning physics discovering
that astrophysics is the best and and
then being able to actually look at the
claims that have been made by Young
Earth Creations about the age of the
universe realizing they all fell apart
in my hands when I had the ability to
look at them for myself so that was
um
and then the reason that didn't affect
sort of my Christianity was that you
know the the most that follows from that
is not God doesn't exist but oh I've
misunderstood it two chapters of the
Bible which there's plenty of chapters
in the Bible I misunderstand so that
wasn't a major sort of uh moment but
that's that was that was quite the
process I mean that was quite the years
of digging into this that and the other
and trying to and I assort you for
having the courage as we like to say to
go into the impossible it takes a lot of
courage and and you're renowned uh for
about the clarity of your presentation
your explanation and the fact that you
do so much Outreach to the public I
really absolute that I have a you know
canara day or say you know we scientists
have a have a moral obligation to to
share what we do and I think we have a
Venom financial interest as well because
if they don't understand what we do yeah
they're gonna stop supporting us yeah
yeah yeah anyway Luke it's been a
pleasure to meet you have you come back
for our part three uh thanks everybody
subscribe uh to uh to follow Luke on all
social media links we'll have those in
the bottom and uh tune in next time for
more exciting content into the
impossible thank you so much thank you
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
[Music]